- Thank you, everybody, so much
for coming in this evening.
And joining us for session
five of 10 questions.
Tonight's question is,
everybody remembers,
what is memory?
And whatever else it is
and whatever the things we
learn from the conversation
that we'll all have together this evening,
one thing memory is this
remarkable human capacity,
this idea of our comprehension
of what isn't with us, who
isn't with us in a room.
And I say that tonight,
because it's with absence
in fact that we begin
this evening's session.
We originalLy have four speakers
scheduled for this evening
as we do every Tuesday evening.
And like each session,
those four guest will have a conversation
around tonight's questions.
Sadly, world arts and cultures professor,
Polly Nooter Roberts, listed
for tonight's session,
passed away in September.
A brilliant scholar, a beloved teacher,
a colleague, a wife, a mother,
Polly brightened so many of our lives
with her brilliant mind, luminous spirit,
unyielding optimism and
boundless generosity
that we will all remember
her tonight of all nights
here within the school.
Polly shared these thoughts
about the role of memory
in her own wonderful research
undertaken as a faculty member
in world arts cultures dance
here in the school of
arts and architecture.
Polly wrote this way regarding memory.
One of the deep subjects of my work
is memory and how memories are
transformed into histories.
But really what memory
is and its transformation
into a historical account
comes down to this.
The telling of a story.
It's the narration of the story
from a particular person's point of view
at a specific moment in time
in front of a certain audience,
that is what becomes history.
And another person reciting another story
in another place is telling history too,
but it may be a completely
different history
because it is a different person
with a different perspective on the past.
In the end, memory is
always a performance.
This evening we continue
to remember Polly.
We hold her absence close to us throughout
this conversation and every
day here within the school.
We write her into our story this evening,
and dedicate this evening's
discussion to her memory.
And with that, let me
introduce this evening's guest.
Let me invite them up to the stage now.
(applauding)
Dr. Darnell Hunt is director of UCLA's
Ralph J. Bunche Center for
African-American Studies.
He's the author of the
Hollywood Diversity Report
and professor of sociology.
His research interest include race, media,
and cultural studies.
Dr. Kelsey martin is a neuroscientist
(audience applauding)
and dean of the David Geffen
School of Medicine at UCLA.
Dr. Martin is a professor
of biological chemistry
and of psychiatry and
bio behavioral sciences,
and has been a leader in UCLA's drive
to promote cross disciplinary cooperation
among scientists in neuroscience
and other brain-related research.
And finally, distinguished
professor, Peter Sellars,
from our own department of
world arts cultures dance,
is an opera theater and festival director
who has gained renowned worldwide
for his groundbreaking and
transformative interpretations
of artistic masterpieces
and collaborative projects
with an extraordinary
range of creative artists.
He's known for exploring
challenging moral issues,
such as race, war, poverty,
and the international refugee
crisis through his work.
And as we have done in previous sessions,
we're going to invite each of our guest
to make a brief presentation.
And from that, enjoy an
evening's conversation
around tonight's question: What is memory?
And we have an agreed order,
and we will begin this
evening with Kelsey Martin.
(applauding)
(faintly speaking)
- My whole research program is around
how are memory stored in the brain.
And so, why do we think about the brain?
It's because we know for
many studies in humans
that when there are lesions in the brain,
for example in the part of
the brain called hippocampus.
It's called hippocampus
because it looks a little like a seahorse.
When there's a stroke there,
when there's some kind of an injury,
the person with that
injury can no longer form
long-term memory.
So their experiences are never actually
encoded into a long=term memory.
Similarly, other parts of the brain
when there are lesions there,
there are alterations in
a way that that individual
perceive the world will behave,
will encode information,
and will in turn transform
that information into memories,
and those memories are
thus stored in the brain.
And we really wanna understand
how it is, that experience,
how our everyday experience
is encoded in that region of the brain.
So, the human brain is shown here.
It's a three-pound organ in our head.
And about well over 100 years ago,
Ramon Y Cajal who was a
Spanish neuroscientist
literally sitting at his
kitchen table with a microscope,
using this beautiful staining method
where you could see individual
nerve cells in the brain.
This was from a pigeon brain.
He saw this and he
realized from looking at it
that there were all these different cells,
and it wasn't a whole gamish.
At the time, it was
thought to be a syncytium.
And you looked at it and
he saw here's one cell
that has this incredible
elaborate arbor of processes.
And he saw that they contacted each other
at specific sites.
And just by looking at that
structure of the brain,
he came up with the idea that
those connections between nerve cells
might be the site where
memories are stored.
So this was not any kind of
molecular biology, no genetics.
It was really by looking at the form
that the neuro cells existed in the brain.
So that's well over 100 years,
and we now know that he was right,
that there's something that
we call synoptic plasticity.
Those sites of contact,
they're called synapse,
they're the re-clasping together,
that those sites, those
synoptic connections
change with our experience.
And in fact, while you're sitting here,
if you remember anything
at the end of this evening,
you will have a different
structure in your brain.
Those nerve cells will be
forming different synapses.
You will have gain some new synapses,
and we have a lot of really, to me,
beautiful empowering tools
for standing to understand
how that process works.
That was over a hundred years ago.
Now we can use tools using
genetics and molecular biology
where we can label nerve cells
using a lot of different
fluorescent proteins.
This is in the part of the brain
called the cerebellum in
the back of your head,
in the back of your brain
that's involved in coordination.
Motor skills, motor learning.
These are beautiful
cerebellar Purkinje neurons
that form these arbors,
and here you can label individual neurons
with different fluorescent proteins,
so you can see what their structure is
and how they contact one another.
Here's a nerve cell that's in your cortex,
the part of your brain that's required for
what we call executive function,
making sure that you
behave professionally.
And we can label the whole neuron in red,
but we can label the individual synapses,
those places where nerve cells
communicate with one another,
and where there's that plasticity
where memories can be stored
with that green label.
And so, over time, one can
look at those individual cells,
you can do something where
you can use genetics to label
multiple cells in what's
called the neural circuit,
and why is this important.
It's because the human brain
has about 100 billion neurons,
and it has about 100 trillion synapses.
It's this incredibly complex circuit.
It's the circuitry that
underlies our perception,
our emotions, our ability to remember,
the way we behave, the way we move,
and all of that changes over time.
It's hard wired when we're born,
but it undergoes this dynamic remodeling.
And so the way that I think about memory
is how does that dynamic
remodeling happen.
We can even take nerve cells, for example,
at a very high powered microscope,
looking at it, stimulating it,
and you can watch over time that these new
sites of contact, these
new synapses will grow.
So that kind of plasticity
is something that
we can now begin to really understand
what are the underlying
molecular mechanisms.
And by understanding that,
the hope is really that
we'll be able to address
disease that involve memory,
whether those are things like
post traumatic stress disorder
or things like Alzheimer's disease
where there's a loss of memory.
And the other thing
that studies like this,
they've revealed over a history of work
for many different people across the globe
are three principles that I
think are really important.
For us as human beings.
One of them is that
there's something called
a critical period in childhood,
and it's really the period
up through adolescence
at which that kind of synapses plasticity
is particularly powerful.
And so our early childhood experiences
are stored in changes in the connectivity
of deep brain structures
in what's called the limbic system
that very powerfully alters
the way that we see the world,
and hence children who
have traumatic experiences
will carry that with them,
and then their subsequent experiences
will be altered by that.
Another features is that emotion
has a powerful impact on
that synaptic plasticity.
So, I'm gonna age myself here,
but if you remember, and I
was really young at the time.
I remember when JFK was killed,
and I remember my mom crying,
and I remember that situation quite well.
I really remember when Price Di died
because it was this very,
there was a lot of emotion.
And that emotion tends to really enhance
plasticity and memory formation.
So there's a lot of work on
what's the role of emotion,
and attention, and alertness
in forming memories.
Another important feature
of memory is repetition,
and I think any student knows this.
There's lots of work
that shows that if you
wanna learn how to play the piano
and you practice once
a week for two hours,
that's not as good as practicing
every day for half an hour.
So that kind of repetition
is a way that our brains
are able to promote that plasticity
and that storage of memory.
So these, I think of myself as
somewhat of what I call a reductionist.
I think of what's the real,
the concrete storage,
what we call the n-gram
of memory in the brain.
And yet I recognize that this
doesn't necessarily capture
what our own individual
experiences of memory are,
and yet it does tell me
something very important
about my own experience of memory,
which is that it's dynamic,
that all of my past experiences
are changing the way that I'm perceiving
any ongoing experience,
and that that in turn
means that memory can be
quite fallible and subjective.
It's not a recording of reality.
It's an act somewhere between recording
and sort of creativity that
comes with your entire past
experience as a human being.
And so I think that that
understanding of the biology
and understanding how the biology explains
that dynamic, subjective
emotional component of memory
holds a lot of promise for
understanding many aspects
of human experience and
of psychiatric disease.
(audience applauding)
- Cheers, thank you.
Kelsey, thank you.
Everyone, Darnell Hunt.
- Alright.
Okay, in many ways, I'm gonna pick up
where Kelsey left off.
She was talking about a very concrete way
of thinking about memory.
I'm gonna talk about ways in which
the social interacts with the biological,
ways in which what happens
to us in our lives,
in our experiences affect
the way the brain remembers.
In social science, we have a
number of different ways of
talking about memory conventionally.
We talk about sensory memory,
which really allows us to retain
snippets of information
from second to second.
For example, seeing a frame of a film
and seeing that over time that
it looks like fluid motion,
because we can remember
those individual images,
or short-term memory
which allows us to kind of
understand the meaning of a sentence
because we remember the
first part of the sentence
to the end of the sentence.
And then we have something
we call long-term memory
which really gets to our connections
with a particular point
in time or a place.
We tend to remember those things
over longer periods of time,
particularly when we're exposed to those
same conditions over again.
That's a conventional way
of thinking about memory
within the social sciences,
which picks up a lot of its insight from
the biological sciences.
Today though, I'm gonna
talk about the intertextual
and meaning making.
And take a second to read this quote here.
It actually connects very well with
something that Brett mentioned
at the very beginning
about Polly and her work.
Why don't you take a second to read this,
and then we'll continue?
The basic idea here is
that as human beings,
storytelling is hardwired into who we are.
We connect with other people,
we communicate by telling stories,
and often those stories
involve our memories.
Today I wanna talk about something called
the circle of culture which,
in a second, you'll see how
this relates to the idea
of what I call intertextual memories.
In here we have a circuit
of five important moments
starting with representation.
And by representation, I
mean the irresistible images,
ideas, utterances,
that shape the way we
think about the world.
And examples of representations
might be things like
race, a concept that defines
people to certain categories.
In sociology, we talk about it
as a social constructed concept.
Or gender,
or any number of other
concepts that are used
to put people into categories
to help us make sense
of what would otherwise
would be a chaotic world.
The insight of this
particular diagram is that
representations connected
to all these other things
like identity, who we are, who we aren't,
who we hope to be.
Production, the types of
things we produce in society,
the way we produce them as a reflection
of who we think we are,
or of the representations
that order our society.
The things we consume.
Advertising, obviously.
I think Kelsey was sort
of referencing this
a few minutes ago, in
terms of representation,
I mean, I'm sorry, repetition
and remembering things.
One of the core, I guess,
practices within advertising
is to repeatedly give the same
message over and over again
to compel people to remember the product
and to hopefully consume it over time.
And then regulation,
how we draw boundaries
between different groups,
who's inside, who's outside.
All of these things are bound up
with the concept of representation,
they affect who we are
in terms of our identity,
what we as a culture
produce, and what we consume.
Now, I wanna move forward to what I call
the media experience.
And here of course representation becomes
a very important part
of what happens when we
experience media text,
movies, television, et cetera.
Representations like race, like gender
information the intertextual memories
that we bring to the media experience.
When we watch something on television,
we don't watch it cold.
We're always watching it in relation
to other things we've seen in the past.
These media text both shape
and are shaped by representation.
That is to say people
who create media text
are trafficking in the representations
that circulate in society.
Those media text become part of
the fluid reservoir of
memories that circulate
as people engage with them.
This is kinda happening at
the macro level in society,
kinda the level above the individual,
the level of collectivities.
If we move more to the micro level
and what's happening with
individuals like you and me,
like those of us sitting in this room,
we are decoding what we're
seeing and hearing on television.
And often that decoding is a product
largely of the memories we
bring to that situation.
We may have encountered
things like this in the past,
which cause us to interpret
it in a particular way.
At the same time, as
individuals, we exist in society.
We're not isolated.
That is to say we interact
with other people.
So there's always decoding
in a social context,
often in the networks in which
we are embedded in society,
our friends, our family, et cetera.
Often our discussions with them,
their interpretations of what we saw
inflect the way we interpret it.
This goes to what we
call negotiated decoding
where we kind of negotiate the meaning
of a particular encounter
on the basis of our own
individual predispositions,
filtered through the lens
of our interactions with important others.
And as you can see,
this flows back into our
intertextual memories,
the cycle repeats itself.
There really is on start or end.
This is an ongoing cycle.
Alright, this is a theoretical model
that's influenced by something known as
British cultural studies,
which was an intellectual tradition
that arose in the 1970s,
largely as a correction to, at the time,
overly deterministic ways of
sort of conceptualizing
the relationship between
meaning making and messages.
There was a belief at one point in time
in the magic bullet theory
that if you send a message,
it will, like a magic
bullet, enter into our brains
and lead to a particular type of meaning.
And that was the
orthodoxy for a long time.
Eventually, however, empirical studies
started to show that it
doesn't quite work that way.
People are amazingly creative at
changing sort of the main
stream or dominant view
of a particular message.
And so the question became,
how do we measure this?
How do we understand this empirically?
And so this model is
meant to try to do this.
The thing I want to emphasize
today of course is that
intertextual memories,
the memories of all the other encounters
we have in our lives,
with media, with messages,
with other people
are an integral part of the process.
So, to kinda work through
this idea really quickly,
I wanna take the case of the
1992 Los Angeles uprisings,
something I've written about in the past.
In fact, I think you reviewed
a chapter from the book I wrote on this.
So, one way of thinking
about the 1992 uprisings,
particularly memories
of the 1992 uprisings
is by looking at the way those events
were depicted on television.
For those who weren't around in 1992,
the 1992 uprisings, at the time,
were described by the LA Times as
the worst riots of the century.
There was over a billion dollars
worth of damage in Los Angeles.
There were 52 people who were killed.
There were thousands arrested.
The event came on the heels
of not guilty verdicts
in the Rodney King beating case.
He was a black motorist who
was pulled over by police.
And it just so happen that a passerby
has camcorder and
recorded the whole thing.
The video was taken to
a local news station
and it went viral.
The thing I wanna emphasize here,
and we can talk more about
this in our discussion,
is that I screen for 15 groups of viewers
on the basis of their race and their class
the exact same 17-minute news clip.
And part of what I
wanted to understand was
how are people making
sense of this news clip
based on their positioning in society.
One of the things I expected
and one of the things I found was that
as they talk about the
event in their groups,
intertextual memories
of other similar events
of movies they had seen, television shows,
speeches they had heard
shaped the way they were
processing the information.
And there was interesting
patterning along racial lines,
in terms of how those
interpretations played out.
So, in closing, and we can continue this
a little bit, in a few
minutes, the actual.
I'll share with you some of
the quotes from the groups.
The way we see things
is affected by what we know or believe.
This is important idea
that was put forward in the early 1970s
as part of this tradition from
a book called Ways of Seeing,
that talked about the subjective nature
of the way we experience
the social worlds around us,
that it's not purely an objective process
that can be measured uniformly
across all viewers, all observers.
In fact, observers bring
different materials
to those encounters,
and one of the important things they bring
is intertextual memory.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you Darnell.
Everybody, Darnell Hunt.
And our final presentation, Peter Sellars.
(faintly speaking)
- We'd be hot now, let's be hot.
Okay.
Thank you, deeply.
My goodness.
I am going to try and go through
some of the same material but
.by a very circuitous route.
And forgive me, but part
of my training as an artist
is that the shortest
distance between two points
means you didn't learn anything.
And so, for me, the long way around
is actually how life works,
and what's not immediately
adjacent turns out to be,
in fact, incredible close.
That question where near
becomes and far becomes near
is one of the main points of memory.
And I would like to pick
up on several things.
First of all, I want to thank Brett
for making these evening.
I'm so happy to meet these two people
that I would not have known.
I've been teaching at UCLA for 30 years.
Hello, finally I'm meeting you tonight.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Just to say, for me, the moral
questions of memory are really profound,
and I wanna deal with what we remember,
what we actually deny,
what we hold and cherish,
and what we can't deal with,
and how we don't deal with,
and how memory operates
as an ethical system,
and what memory actually has to be
with the way you decide to live your life,
which is two words that
are very important to me
as a performer and somebody
who organizes performance,
remember
and repentance.
What we do in performance
is we take the voice of
those who are no longer here,
and we give them new bodies, our own.
And we invite other people
to speak through us.
We create a spirit possession.
We create a moment in which our identity
is suddenly blurred with another identity.
And what I want to just mention tonight
is a performance that I've just come from
putting on in Madrid.
It's still running for the next two weeks,
anyone who's going to Madrid.
Of two Japanese Noh plays,
14th century Buddhist, Zen Buddhist plays.
And we've titled the evening
one of the lines from one of the plays,
which is Only the Sound Remains.
What it means when you lose someone
but you're remembering them all day,
all night,
and you're still in
conversation with them.
Their physical presence is gone,
but their voice is with you,
and only the sound remains.
In the way in which sound carries memory,
the way in which a piece
of music carries memory,
the way in which our
soundtrack all day long
is actually the way we're
ordering our memories.
And sound exactly because of it's fluidity
and because of its non-material nature.
The way it eludes any
attempt to organize it,
the way voices flow
through your consciousness,
who you still keep thinking of,
and how that operates of course
in spiritual path because
Jesus, and Buddha, and Muhammad
are not here,
but their voice remains with us.
And then what it means to remember,
that is to say Jesus is asking
you to embody his words,
and you have to offer
your body to those voices
and that speech,
and walk in somebody else's footsteps,
and actually begin to acknowledge
that you're not alone and you're not,
in fact, yourself.
But all these voices
are moving through you,
and inspiring your actions,
and inspiring your next moves,
which is what brings me
to the word repentance,
which is things we've all
done that we're not proud of,
and we feel we have to live
our lives to make up for that
to somehow make that good,
and what it means that
you have certain memories
that are very difficult,
and you have to live in a way
that brings some equilibrium,
some balance, and some justice.
And the way justice operates in memory,
where we know something
unjust has happened,
and we live with that memory of injustice
and what it means to live every day
as a way to counteract those
memories and correct them.
Or, the same way,
moments of deep beauty in our
life that we're searching for
to enhance and to allow them to flower.
So I'm gonna just mention briefly,
briefly with God,
the Buddhist sense of store consciousness
just to get at the zen place.
And store consciousness is understanding
that every single gesture you make
and every thought you have,
and every thing you say
becomes a seed in your consciousness.
And your consciousness
is all of those seeds
planted across many, many lifetimes.
And your life is which
seeds you choose to water
and pay attention to
or which seeds you
actually recognize as weeds
and try to pull out by the roots,
and what the garden of your life is
is based on how you order your memories,
which memories are the place
from which you want to grow,
what is the tree that the
seed of a certain action
results in across your whole lifetime.
You make one action at
one moment in your life,
and it becomes a tree
across your whole life,
that seed.
And to take something
you spoke of so movingly,
which is that memories are not,
are not frozen.
It's quite the opposite, they're alive.
And just to say if I ask
everybody in the room tonight
to just have that memory and image,
take a snapshot of your mother,
and hold that image in
front of you now, tonight,
and you will take an image from a moment,
a powerful moment between the two of you.
And you can see your mother.
But as you hold that
image now in your mind,
you see things you didn't see
at the time when you took that snapshot,
because you know more
about your mother now
than you did when that snapshot occurred,
and you know a little
more about the context
of what was going on than you knew then.
So what happens is not only do that memory
not remain stable,
but you're adding to that
memory new information
and new ways of understanding
and new perspectives,
which you've showed so
beautifully in that graph.
And what it means that every
single instant in your life
is continuing to grow with you.
And so not only does
memory not remain the past,
but memory is no moment
remains its on separate self,
but actually is transforming
and continues to grow.
Every second in your life
continues to be active
for the rest of your life.
So the way we demonstrate that in theater
is to actually step into other bodies
and to move through
images that allow us to deal with memory,
and I would just say,
to quote Toni Morrison,
I think one of the most
powerful images as ghosts
is recognizing that
we're haunted by ghosts,
that ghost that are part
of all of our lives.
And in the arts, the ghosts frequently,
a powerful way that you can
actually give form to a memory
that is otherwise extremely elusive.
Japanese Noh theater invented in the,
in basically the 1300s,
at a high moment of zen, culture.
The place all have the same structure.
A wandering priest
goes through a certain landscape,
and the first part of the play
is a very specific tracing
of a geography, of a journey,
real place names,
what the temperature is,
what the water is like there,
what the sky was, what the weather was.
All this detail of tracing a journey
and trying to retrace a footstep.
And then the priest
arrives at a place where
he decides, "I'd like to stay here."
Sits down, see someone raking leaves.
Asks the person who's raking leaves,
"What happened in this place?"
That's part one of the play.
Part two of the play
is the spirit of the person
raking leaves returns,
but now as a spirit
in a whole new costume and mask,
and dances out
that she was a warrior
who dressed in armor,
people didn't know who she was,
and she was killed at this spot,
and the person who killed
her was her husband.
And that was 700 years ago.
And that is the person
raking leaves here today,
because the spirit is trapped
here in this place forever.
And then the spirit disappears.
And the quality of understanding
that not only do human
beings have a memory,
but places have memories,
and that trauma, or moments of
exceptional beauty in a place
live on through the people
who live in that place,
and that trauma is not over with
at one historical moment,
but actually across centuries.
That trauma repeats itself and affects
people in a certain place.
And also moments of beauty
and moments of truth.
So, the play that I'm
dealing with is called
Tsunemasa in Japanese,
and it's a priest who makes a ceremony
for a young man who died in battle,
because this young man killed someone
and then was killed.
And the young man I think
is the priest's lover.
But in Asia, in many Buddhist cultures,
there's a formal practice of
when somebody leaves the world in pain,
when someone leaves the world
in terrible circumstances,
you make a ceremony for their spirit
one year after their death
and three years after their death,
because nobody wants angry
spirits and hurt spirits
wandering around because
it's terrible for everyone.
And you create a ceremony
to call back the spirit
of the person who's gone and say,
"You died horribly, and we know that,
"and we have to acknowledge your sadness."
We have to acknowledge the injustice,
we have to acknowledge all the things
that were not acknowledged
in your lifetime.
We have to let you know, we remember you,
and we want to make
good what was very bad.
We want to make just what was unjust.
We wanna offer you the compassion
and love that you did not feel then,
and we're gonna create a ceremony.
And of course the beginning of theater,
the invention of the performing arts
in most cultures is
performing for the dead,
is actually the reason we perform
is to tell the dead we remember them,
to ask them to remember us kindly,
better than we deserve to be remembered,
ask them to favor us,
and to somehow put back into balance
something that is deeply out of balance.
And we can't live another day
with a memory of what was wrong.
This play begins, is that ceremony,
and the spirit of this deeply
damaged young man comes back.
And it's a harrowing middle of the night.
And finally, the young man has to
return back into another world because
the spirits can't make it
through the earth's atmosphere.
Only the voices
can make it through.
And if I could quote the
Ezra Pound translation.
I perceive no form but a voice.
And the spirit says,
"It is the faint sound
alone that remains."
The priest says, "But
I saw the form really."
The spirit says, "It is
there if you see it."
The priest says, "I can see."
The spirit says, "Are you
sure you see it, really?"
The priest says, "Oh,
"do I or do I not see you?"
The chorus takes over
for this ghost's voice.
Changeful Tsunemasa, full of
the universal unstillness,
looked back upon the world.
His voice was heard there,
a voice without form.
None might see him,
but he looked out from his phantom world,
a dream
that gazed on our world.
The priest says, "It is strange.
"The figure was there and is gone.
"Only the thin sound remains.
"The film of a dream, perhaps."
And then the spirit
returns to the other world.
And these lines by the
great Japanese poet, Theami,
conclude the play.
And I don't mean to
emphasize what's negative,
but I tend to feel that most people live
with so many regrets, so many things that
deeply, deeply at the core of your being
you're trying to compensate for.
And again, I just can't thank you enough
for bringing up the LA Uprising,
and for what it means when
something that was never ever
even acknowledged correctly
is then further misremembered.
But in fact, it's a moment of sorrow.
It's a moment of deep sorrow
that makes a deep impression on us.
These are the last words of the play,
which by the way is 3 1/2 pages long.
And the performance takes
90 minutes or two hours.
So the material is just you
live inside this material
the same way you live inside your memory
that something took a second in real life,
and you spent weeks
arguing with that person
once they're gone,
and going back to that
conversation and said,
"What do they mean when they said this?"
And they said, "No, but they misheard me,"
and you replay everything for
weeks, and months, and years
that in real life took seconds.
That's the way the Japanese
invented this form of theater,
what it means that something that happened
for a second in your life
has this endless existence,
and goes at the infinite time and space.
The sorrow of the heart
is a spreading around
of quick fires.
Think of your beautiful arbors.
The sorrow of the heart
is a spreading around
of quick fires.
The flames are turned to thick rain.
The sorrow of the heart
is a spreading around of quick fires.
The flames are turned into rain.
He slew by the sword and the slain.
The red wave of blood rows in fire,
and now he buns with that flame.
He bade us, "Put out the light."
Oh, the last word of the spirit was,
"It's a sorry face that I make here.
"Put down the lights if you see me."
He bade us, "Put out the lights."
He flew as a summer moth.
His brushing wings were storm.
His spirit is gone in the darkness.
So we're talking about
living with the sound
of those brushing wings in the dark.
(all applauding)
- Thank you.
Peter, Kelsey, Darnell, thank you
each for those presentations.
I think as we did last week,
let's take two minutes
to take a deep breath,
stand up, shake yourself
out if you'd like.
Lean over to the neighbor
that you're sitting next to
or someone behind you.
Share a thought with them,
ask a question, hear their response.
We can do the same up here,
and we'll come back online
in about two minutes.
Thank you.
Thank you everyone.
After those three terrific presentations,
what I've just suggested to
our three guests this evening
is maybe open the conversation
up between the three of them,
having now seen the presentations
by your fellow guest this evening.
And I'm gonna turn it over to
the three of you for a minute.
- Well, there's one thing that I,
listening to my colleagues talk,
that I was thinking about,
and I'd like to hear your thoughts about,
and it has to do with,
we've been talking about remembering,
but part of remembering is forgetting.
What does that mean to forget?
I know from study, from
biology of memory studies,
that we don't really forget,
that we think we forget,
but there are these
memories that are present
that will come out, and that
we're not even aware of.
There's something called inhibition
that gets placed on top of those memories.
And then in a certain situation,
that might come away,
and it's actually there.
So I like to just talk for a moment about
forgetting and what that means.
- That's an interesting question.
When I was conducting the study
that I referred briefly a few moments ago,
one of the things I was
trying to explore was
sort of how when people
get together in a group
they collectively negotiate
the meaning of something.
And one of the theories
called informational influence is that
when you're in a group and there's kind of
a dominant understanding of something,
the question is what happens
when the group discusses it.
Well, there's something
called group polarization
where the view can even
become more dominant over time
as people are reinforcing
one another's understandings.
And one of the arguments
for how that happens
is something called informational
influence theory that,
people who come to the group
with a predisposition towards seeing
something in a certain way
may have forgotten some of the arguments
to support that position.
But when they get around
people like themselves,
and they hear that information again,
they're like, "Aha, that's right."
And they actually harden their
adherence to that point of view.
So this is something that I actually found
in all the groups I study.
Most of the groups, if you sort of
did this quasi experimental
thing where you measured
kind of where they were on a scale
when they first came to the meeting,
by the end, they're way over here.
And this was true in every group,
and the scales will go
in different directions,
depending upon the basic
understanding of the group.
And so forgetting was a big part of that,
and then remembering,
once it was brought up
in group conversation.
- One of the ethical issues
for me so much right now,
in America right now, is this
in order to create the mythical golden age
that a bunch of people
keep wanting to create.
That's only possible if you
forget a whole lot of stuff.
(all laughs)
And that forgetting is highly organized,
and you decide what
things are inconvenient,
and they are just erased while
you create out of memory,
something super evil called nostalgia,
in which something was never true.
But you're damn sugarcoating,
and golden glow,
and extr maple syrup,
create something where the
original taste is actually gone,
and something has morphed
into a wish fulfillment of
something that supports your
own sense of superiority.
And you can say, "I'm on top of this,
"and I know when there was good time,
"and this isn't it."
And conveniently choose to not include
not only what was happening
to other people then,
but what you were actually doing,
and what the implications of that are.
And so, for me, that total
constructed forgetting
is a pretty intense thing,
and we're seeing it all
over the world right now,
and we're seeing it as
a nightmare epidemic.
- I think that's one of
the reasons why we see
different groups bringing
different memories
to these encounters, because
the experiences are different.
And someone may experience something as
the good old times are great in many ways.
And they can do this because
they are relatively privileged
in that particular moment,
and other people of course
wouldn't see it that way,
so they would bring other
memories to the encounter.
And so we see a lot of
this in the study I did,
it was 1992.
I mean the whole question
of whether not it is a,
quote unquote, riot versus rebellion
differ very sharply, depending
upon those backgrounds
and the experiences
that people brought in.
A lot of the black informants in the study
saw this as a chance for
the voiceless to be heard
in ways that they
couldn't be heard before.
Other groups of course brought in memories
that sparked fears of various sorts.
And this was to be avoided.
It was definitely a riot,
which if you look at
the definition of riot,
senseless, it doesn't
really have any basis
in terms of moving us
in a positive direction.
And so there were very
different takes on this,
based on the memories that
people brought to bear.
And I think that, for me at least,
it fits very nicely with
the way you're kind of
articulating this whole idea of nostalgia
and differential, I guess,
value that groups places on the past,
on different parts of the past.
- Again, I was just so
moved by these diagrams.
- Micrograph, not diagrams.
It's real biology.
(all laughs)
I think of graph is like something
that somebody drew or made up.
These are like, this is
what's in your brain.
(all laughs)
- At a moment in time.
I mean one of the points that
you brought to immediately
is the idea of,
if memory is anything, it's
a fundamentally dynamic--
- Changing all the time, always changing.
And I even, you know when you talk about
the play of a woman remembering
700 years ago,
I can't help, but I really do feel like
a total scientific geek.
But I think about the fact that there are
these things called epigenetic marks
that go from generation to generation
actually change the way that your DNA
is marked by your past ancestry
and your past experiences.
It's gonna change the way that
that whole circuitry works.
And of course I'm saying
that as if okay, so,
I recognize as a scientist,
we're also making up
stories about what we see.
I showed you that picture of those
neurons that Ramon y Cajal looked at
over a hundred years ago.
He made up a story about
what was going on there.
Another person saw it and
made a different story.
It turns out that Ramon y Cajal
was right about the story that he made.
So it's this kind of interplay
between what we think is real biology,
what we know in the story we're
telling ourselves about it.
- [Darnell] It's the
social and the biological.
- Yeah, and it's sort of a metaphor.
For me, I listen to that and I go,
oh, that's epigenetics,
that transgenerational
long history that we have
as human beings.
- I was truck also by the three billion
perspectives at which you
approach the question.
The degree to which your own creative
and professional fields are themselves,
the kinds of memory structures
for the holding of ideas.
Ideas about memory in this case.
Your hundred year quick
summary of brain sciences,
your field is also the
repository of those ideas.
- It's one of the things that
I really love about science
is that it all builds upon
discoveries that others make.
It's always building upon discovery
or enabling technology or
something, learn something.
Sometimes it's wrong
and you have to learn,
oh that was,
(laughs)
and you have to go another direction,
so you can go down the wrong
pathway if you think that
things are written in stone in a textbook,
but it does build on.
It's Newton's, you stand
on the shoulders of giants
and you see you further because of that.
To me that's a pretty remarkable
adventure.
- The Japanese
Noh version of that
is that this year's flowers
came from last year's seeds.
- [Kelsey] It's beautiful.
- And that it's this completely ongoing,
and it's a continuous transition,
and it doesn't end.
And the more deeply you look into...
Again, if you're looking
for your great grandmother,
look into the eyes of your granddaughter.
That's really what we're seeing,
is this deep continuity,
and this sense that something
is not just evolving,
but it actually is reaching
in very profound ways across generations.
And I think just living with thoughts
that are not your own in the same way,
your eyes are also not your own,
and your ears are your grandfather.
You're actually carrying around with you
a lot of stuff that's not just you.
And that is extremely powerful.
- It is a pretty
prominent theater, film,
and television professor
here at UCLA years ago that
influenced my thinking about
the way people engaged with media.
His name Teshome Gabriel.
- [Peter] Oh my god, you're kidding.
- I'm not kidding.
- [Peter] Teshome is the greatest.
- Yeah, he's amazing.
- Excuse me, may we have a
memorial service for Teshome tonight?
- [Darnell] That's right, that's right.
- Thank you Teshome Gabriel.
Oh my goodness, thank you.
Thank you.
- Yeah, he introduced me to
British culture studies actually
as I was trying to get my hands around
this whole idea of meaning construction.
I'm trying to find the quote
from him actually that...
I remember the gist of it,
but I wanna get it right.
He basically said that...
Let's see, where is it?
(mumbles)
Okay.
Here we go.
He said,
so he was interested in
basically the conditions
confronted my marginalized
groups in society.
And the ways in which those conditions
lead to the creation of what
you call the collective memory,
and it kinda goes to the
point you were making
about the memories that we carry with us
that linger for years.
And these memories can often deviate
from the official history that
certain groups that are in control
are able to kind of encode
certain understandings of the past.
And he said this memory, quote,
decisively frames the
production and reception
of commercial culture for these groups.
And despite dominant efforts
to privilege certain meanings,
the meanings associated society
are never completely suture.
And so his argument
was that we are always,
because of the experiences we encounter
and the groups to which we belong,
particularly marginalized groups,
able to overcome those dominant messages
by the memories we
bring to the encounters.
And that's kind of what
I was trying to explore
with the LA uprisings,
and the way different
groups were interpreting
the same official news
text of that evening.
- And what it means when we move through
different geographies
which of course shape our entire way we
are living in our body.
And one of the deepest things that Teshome
was able to demonstrate
over and over again
in his third cinema is this idea that
as people are moving across
different phases of their lives,
if you've had to reinvent
yourself four times
in order to be where you are now,
the way you read everyone
else's story is different,
because you've actually had to tell
a lot of different stories.
And your story has not been
allowed to be the same,
because in America, for example,
with immigration and refugees,
we only allow three stories to be told.
And if you tell one of those stories,
you have a chance of getting in.
And so, people have to actually
falsify their experience
at the immigration interview,
because whatever actually happened to you
is not on the list.
And Teshome's brilliance is that how many
ways people have learned
to tell their story
and have learned to remember
things that have been deliberately erased,
erased by the culture
that's surrounding them.
And how do you keep those
things alive not only in memory,
but then translate your
memory into practice.
And that's a really powerful thing
that we're living with right now.
- [Darnell] Definitely.
- I think we're gonna
open the conversation up
to the entire room as we've done before.
I think we have some microphones
out and about and over here on the side.
- You sort of answered my question
a little bit in that last discussion,
but I was curious about
we live in a time where
information is mass produced
and mitigated on an unprecedented scale
through social media and the internet.
And so in some ways,
we have so much more access
to different kinds of collective
memory or personal memory.
But I feel like that
mitigation also impacts
what we were discussing
about the culture circuit
and intertextual memory.
And so how do we facilitate
more of those conversation
where people come together
and they bring their different
interpretations of events.
And instead of being polarized or hardened
into their former belief, they are,
that plasticity is encouraged.
And I guess I was just wandering
what all of your perspectives on that are.
- Well, maybe I'll take
the first stab at that.
That's a great question.
I think one of the reason why
when I was asked to do this
that I picked this particular example
is because I mean it's an old example.
It comes from 25 years ago.
But for me, it really
speaks to the present moment
in terms of the siloization
of our culture in many ways,
the ways in which mini groups
who are living in these echo chambers
where they're only hearing
ideas and thoughts that
reinforce their predispositions,
and there aren't as many opportunities
for us to kinda come together,
or rather technology has allowed us
to avoid having to come together.
I guess that's the better way to put it.
I mean there are opportunities
to come together,
but it's easier not to do that.
And I think it leads to the
type of polarization we see.
We see it in small groups,
and that's what I was able
to show in the study I did,
this whole phenomenon of
small group polarization
based on all these mechanism
that we talked about,
like selectively forgetting
and then remembering,
and "Oh, that's right.
"Well, now I'm gonna
be even more staunched
"in this particular idea."
I think it really is about
finding ways to make our
communities more inclusive
and bringing more people into the tent
and having conversations
that cross the boundaries
that social media has allowed us
to erect in very regular
and patterned ways.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- There are a couple
ways I think about this,
and part of the way I'm framing it is,
again, to come back in
my discipline in a way,
which is that...
Two things, one is I think I'm aware that
fear really changes the
way we process information
has incredibly profound impact on how we
perceive things and
how we remember things.
And so I think that there's a need
to really be very
cognizant of how much fear
is driving the information
that's coming in.
And then the other part is that
I think there's a real need to recognize
when I was talking about how
early childhood experience
is this critical period
for shaping the brain.
There are really profound studies
that show, for example,
that learning languages
when you're very young,
in the first year of life,
you're not learning the language,
but you're hearing, for example,
a language that has different tones.
If you don't hear that in
your first year of life,
you can't even those
distinctions later in your life.
So it really shapes the
way you perceive the world.
And I think that there's
a reality to that,
to recognize that our brains
have been wired in a way
that we see things through the lens
of the people we've been around.
That to me is a little bit liberating
in the sense that if that were recognized,
there might be more of
a openness to saying,
"I'm seeing things
incredibly subjectively."
And to go back to you,
we're talking about zen traditions.
There's this tradition of
zen mind, beginner's mind.
If your mind is always
being changed by experience,
there's no really beginner's mind,
but you can at least
try to get towards that
where you recognize that your experience
are really shaping how
you perceive the world.
- Just to go one step, next step,
which is of course that
emptiness, that beginner's mind,
that understanding that
everything is empty actually.
And emptying it of all the associations,
all the meanings, and really beginning
to try and find
the place at which things are empty
is very, very, very powerful thing to do.
And a simple thing, for example,
just working in theater,
is, for me, whenever I'm
putting something on stage,
I have to make sure the actor
is playing the opposite.
In Japanese Noh drama,
it says if you're going to
be an angry person on stage,
you have to be very quiet,
and very balanced, and
very self-possessed.
It would be incorrect
to show an angry person out of control.
You always have to put
a little of the opposite
to make sure the truth is there.
And that's one of the things as art,
we're always dealing
with the difference
between art and propaganda.
Propaganda is trying to
convince you of something,
and therefore it's telling
one side of the story.
So, what we always want to do
on stage is the shy person,
if you have an actor
act like a little mouse,
it's ridiculous.
The shy person is probably the
loudest person in the room.
And so you always have a dramatic choice
that's the opposite of the obvious choice,
and you make sure that
you're balancing everything
with its opposite,
because everything has to
contain its opposite to be true.
And that begins to create
some sense of balance,
some sense of equilibrium.
And for the actor, it gives them something
or her something to play against
that actually creates a depth,
and creates a complexity
of emotional experience.
And you're never doing a one for one
obvious correlation,
but you make everybody have to go
through the opposite of what it is
they're supposedly expressing.
And that creates something
like the complexity
of human consciousness.
- All the way up on the right side there,
I see a hand up.
- I'm wondering if certain issues
that we're facing in terms
of memory and attention
are helping to increase our sense of
tribalism and also our
sense of...
How would I say this?
Very easily instigated outrage.
For instance, some of my professors,
when I was here as a student
in the English lit department
spoke of people
reciting Homer's entire works from memory.
When I was growing up, pre-digital age,
I had 100 phone numbers in my head.
Now I can barely remember
my own phone number
to give out to people.
Also, there's a lot of issue
with the tension I think.
There's a lot of, correct me if I'm wrong,
a lot of neuro biological
studies out right now
that attention is rapidly changing.
People's attention
spans are quite shorter.
I'm wondering if these two issues,
memory which we're relying on
our devices for all the time,
why remember anything
when you can look it up,
and also diminished attention
are contributing to these other
issues we're talking about.
- I would agree with that,
and I think part of the issues is that
those technologies are evolving
a lot more quickly than
our brains are evolving.
And I think that,
a couple things,
it's important to realize that we don't,
our brain, when we perceive things,
we actually are making
up half of what we see.
If you figure out what
is coming into your retina
and what you're looking at,
we're making up half of it,
but there's so much
stuff coming in right now
that I do think it is...
Maybe there just isn't the time to really
put everything together in a
way that's very thoughtful.
I remember my daughter
in high school took a
poetry class,
and the English teacher, when I asked him,
why having a whole
semester just on poetry.
I was delighted,
but he was very explicit about it,
and he said it's because
it's so important if
you're 15, 16 years old
to have to take time to read a poem,
really read a poem carefully
and spend your time reading the poem.
And it made me realize
how rarely that happens.
I grew up with that,
but I certainly feel that
my children, my students,
they don't have as much time.
And at the medical school,
I can tell you that
as a physician, you are now,
when you see a patient,
you look at the patient and
you talk to the patient,
but you are with the monitor
that tells you their
entire medical history,
and some cases their entire imaging data,
their lab data, their genomic data.
So I think how we learn how to
process all that information,
and whether that leads to divisiveness,
it certain leads to kind of
a sense of being overwhelmed.
- I think that people
in the midst of being confronted
with all this information,
they have to find ways
to quickly organize it,
which allows us to, rather
prompts us to rely upon
representations, the concept
that I mentioned earlier,
which get into these types of divisions
and constructions and categorizations
of people and groups
and the familiar versus
what's not familiar.
And so, I can see how
we're trying to play catch up
in terms of our own development
in keeping up with these
new technologies that
we could revert back to some of these more
comfortable tendencies.
They, in the long run, I
think are very dangerous.
- And I think spending time with the texts
is also like spending time with people.
What it means in the
history of spirituality
that most of these texts,
the Bible, the Quran,
the Buddhist sutras
were never written down
for several centuries,
and people learn them by heart.
And what it is right now
if you're a Tibetan monk
is you don't have a pile of books.
You actually have memorized
every one of these texts,
and what it means to
know something by heart,
what it means to have
gone through this text
700 times in one day until you begin to,
new meanings begin to reveal themselves,
when it's also one rather
than looking at somebody
and guessing who they are in one second,
what it means to spend
quality time with someone
and learn that all the things
you thought someone was,
of course they're none of those things,
which is not just occasionally,
that's all with everyone you meet.
You're wrong about almost everything.
And until you actually
spend time with someone,
for one thing, they're trying to convince
you of something that they're not as well.
I'm not blaming one side.
But what it takes to spend time
to get to know who
someone really is behind
what all those appearances are.
That's just time, investment
of time and attention.
And that quality of attention
can move to how they're dressed
and the Sherlock Holmes thing
to a deeper place,
which is actually the Sufi place
where you're able to look and listen
because you're self-focused very deeply.
One Sufi master who I toured with for
several years of my life,
a great Nubian oud player.
We would be in some crowded restaurant
in Los Angeles or Berlin,
and he point to a table on
the other side of the room.
And he'd say "Okay, Peter,
what are they saying?"
I would say, "Hamza, this
restaurant is so loud.
"Everything is so crazy."
And he said, "You don't listen.
"You don't know how to listen.
"Focus on that table and
tell me what they're saying."
- [Kelsey] That's
eavesdropping, I'm sorry.
(laughs)
- Yeah, no, but it's also,
in the Sufi thing, it's about healing.
It's about actually
knowing most human beings
are trying to prevent you
from understanding who they are,
and you have to reach inside
and be able to look in someone's eyes
and see everything that's
ever happened to them
in a way that maybe they themselves
don't even acknowledge or understand.
And so, some of that level of perception,
anyway, thank you for this remark,
because it really is about a time,
but of course time by
itself isn't anything
because you can waste 10
years or use five minutes.
It's the quality of attention
that's happening within that time.
And again, that's one of the reasons
theater was invented
and portrait painting was invented,
was so you would spend the
time to look at someone,
not just to glance,
but actually look deeply.
And that Rembrandt would go
and sit with some old lady
up stairs in the slums
who no one would pay attention to
and Rembrandt spends two weeks with her,
and looks deeply into her eyes
and paints her left sleeve,
and then writes on the bottom,
"The biblical prophet is Esther."
And sees in some old lady in the slum,
a biblical prophetess.
And that quality of looking
is really what we're
talking about as artist
is looking past the surface
into the layers of the lives.
- Back down to the front of the room,
just so that we can move it around.
Yes, right there.
- Hi.
I've always been curious
about the correlation between
memory and dreams,
and the art of dreaming
has always been very intriguing to me.
What do you think shapes our dreams?
Could it be our past memories
telling us a story as you said?
Could it possibly be
warnings for the future?
Or is it something that we will simply
never be able to understand?
- That's great.
- Well, I know what I--
(all laughs)
- I can be wrong.
- Okay, science, please,
come to our rescue.
- No, no, no, no, no.
(all laughs)
I mean there is this part that there's
memory that you get,
you replay a lot of different things
and you put them together
in all sorts of different
ways in your memory.
And at least in studies we can look at
animals that have lived in
an enriched environment,
and you can look at how
their brains are firing,
and you watch them navigate through a maze
and you see all the parts of the circuits
in their brain that are active.
And then while they're asleep,
you see the whole thing replayed again.
So that may not be all that there is,
but it kinda tells me
that's not how I look in my own memories,
so I look at them,
I mean my own dreams,
I look at them and I go
boy, what did that mean.
But I also do think,
well, there must've been
something that went on that I did,
wasn't really paying attention to,
but I knew was there,
and I'm replaying it somehow,
making it to a different story.
- Yeah, I don't know what dreams mean.
I certainly don't know
what my dreams mean.
The point that I was trying to make
with that particular quote,
and it was a book that
really talked about,
a lot of it was based on neuroscience,
i mean the person who wrote the book.
And I've kinda used the book,
and it's been used in this way before
to talk about the
importance of story telling
and how important it
is to tell our stories
and what our stories mean.
And it was really the
form that dreams take.
I mean dreams take the form of stories.
I guess that's one way
of thinking about it,
regardless of whether
or not those stories are
reenactments of the past or
premonitions of the future
or some weird mishmash of the two.
It's really the story that key,
and that memory is sort of
told to stories basically.
I mean history, his story, her story.
We're talking about stories.
- And also genuinely
that we're not just
forever in the damn past.
What it means to create a future
is to actually be able
to say, "I have a dream."
That is an incredibly powerful
place to move forward from,
and we all need every day to move forward.
Yes, we're dragging all this stuff,
but there's gotta be some stuff
that hasn't been done, hasn't been seen,
is not already lived,
and that's why we're on earth
because some stuff hasn't happened yet.
- Wonderful.
There were questions all the
way up in the back there.
Yes, right in the middle.
If we can get a microphone up there,
do we have one?
Sorry, right here?
Should we do this?
Perfect.
- I wonder if you people could speak to
what happens with traumatic situations
that are in our memory
when they're dealt with psychedelics.
- You mean the...
So there was a traumatic experience
and then there's psychedelics,
or traumatic experience
during psychedelic use?
- [Audience Member] No, no, no.
All of the therapeutic things
that are being done now,
they're being reinstated now where
they're actually treating people
to overcome their debilitating
effects of trauma.
So what's going on?
That's a memory that gets changed?
- I do believe that it's a way of
opening the doors of perception,
that it's a way of
increasing that plasticity
in your brain so that you realize that
if you have a traumatic
experience that has
led to a very strong sort of wiring,
so that everything reminds you,
any little thing reminds you
of that traumatic experience of
psychedelics will help
rewire your brain in a way,
and they will allow you to see
things in a slightly different way.
Again, I'm telling you that,
But there's no honest
evidence that that happens,
except that it does allow individuals
to experience their past
experiences in a different way.
- And maybe if I could just also add that,
again, we just keep pathologizing trauma,
and not getting that
trauma is also the key
to your breakthrough,
the key to the breakthrough
the plan to come out of trauma.
And the deepest, deepest
and most creative things
come out of trauma and deep trauma.
And I don't wanna just keep insisting
that trauma is a disaster,
and must be eliminated
surgically, but the opposite,
is please go into the trauma and open it,
and open it into a creative space.
Open into a deeply creative space
because you're not the only
person carrying trauma.
And actually, everybody needs
to be able to deal with that.
And so, any possible
creativity emerging from that
is very powerful.
And I would just say one
of the greatest things
about living in the
United States of American,
it became the greatest
country in the world
because it was mad by a
lot of traumatized people.
And the need to have a better idea,
and the need to overcome,
and the need to rise above,
and the need to move forward and press on
came from people escaping
holocaust or enduring them here.
And that's the greatness of this country.
- Right up there.
In the back row right here.
- [Audience Member] I'll just shout.
- Okay.
- It's so near.
- Thank you.
I'm curious about the
influence or the effect
of our senses on our memories.
I notice for example that sometimes
a smell can take you right back
to another place in your
life or another time,
and I assume that memory
is partially related to things that we see
or things that we hear or taste.
And I was curious if anybody had any
thoughts a the role that our senses,
as opposed to where we stand in society,
what gender we are, what race we are,
how memory is affected by our senses.
- I opened up by talking about
conventional social scientific ways
of thinking about memory,
and sensory memory was the
very first one I had listed.
I think I gave the example of sight
and the way that if
you're looking at a movie,
you remember each frame,
ad you see this fluid motion
that in fact is actually
individual frames.
And so, yeah, I mean the
point you made earlier
about smell about sounds,
I mean all those things
can trigger memories
and be quite deep seated.
I mean you would know more
about the architecture
of that in terms of how
it works in the brain,
but certainly we do look at
those precursors to memories.
- I mean smell and taste
have very profound effects on memory.
And if any of you have
ever eaten something,
and then gotten sick,
that is one of the strongest ways
of forming a memory
that you never wanna eat that fruit again,
or it takes an awful long time,
and it gets back to that sort of very,
I hate to use this word,
but people talk about it as
a primitive form of memory,
and it is.
If you're a worm in the dirt
and you eat something bitter
that makes you really sick,
you're not gonna eat that again.
And similar for smell, I
mean Proust, the madeleine,
it brought back this incredible
deep rich memory.
I thought about it with the sound.
The sounds that you were
talking about, the voices,
and certainly music.
Music, how many people?
We were listening to songs about memory
and making comments,
but one of them really reminded
me of being in high school,
and it makes me, brings
me back in a way that
very little else will do that.
- And I would just also emphasize
that we are so taught to value
the part of the world that
surrounds us made by men.
And in fact,
your grandmother's cooking
shaped your life more than anything.
It's actually those smells,
it's actually those tastes
that are the deepest, deepest
things shaping your life,
because that's your grandmother
and your mother shaping your life
every single day during
those crucial years.
And so, those smells and tastes
go so deep,
and go so deep into your earliest
and most profound emotions.
I would also just emphasize
the beauty of synesthesia,
which is what we work
within the arts a lot,
that there's the smell that
you can associate with the sound,
or a sound you associate
with a taste or a touch.
We haven't talked that much about touch,
but some of the artist that
I work with work almost
exclusively with touch
and the way in which your
memory is connected to touch
is very powerful,
and the way a certain type of touch
will trigger all kinds of feelings,
all kinds of memories,
all kinds of sensations.
The thing that I love about
those is unlike sight,
which has been organized by batteries of
Republican's operatives
who get up earlier than
you do by three hours.
And we've categories a bunch of things,
and we have labels on
them as you were saying.
What's so beautiful about taste and smells
is they're so hard to label.
They're so hard to produce.
Those are those kind of people,
these are these kind of people.
Those are the good people,
these are the bad people.
It's really hard to
organize taste that way.
It's really difficult to
put those same kind of
egregious value judgements,
whereas we're so trained to
parse the visual world that way
and look at people a certain way.
But in fact, once you get into the taste,
it moves in a whole other directions
that you're not in control of.
So I'm very partial to
those particular senses.
Thank you.
- Hi, I have a question.
I was wondering, you
guys have talked about
riots, and anger, and PTSD, and trauma,
and I was wondering.
I'd love to hear you
guys elaborate more on
the process of healing.
How do we pause the knowledge
but also heal and move forward?
- I'm trying to think about that
in the context of memory.
Well, I mean, I think healing
involves confronting trauma
on some very basic levels.
I mean I think any psychoanalyst
will tell you that.
Kind of engaging with the memories that
kinda flow from the trauma
allows you to bring it in the present
and to analyze it in ways that
subconsciously maybe you're not aware of,
and allows you to kinda,
again, it must have
some effect in the brain
in terms of how you think about it
from that point forward,
and creates the condition
of possibility to kinda,
it involves other groups
to engage with those groups that
may have been off limits in the past.
So I think on some very basic level,
you have to acknowledge
whatever it was that created the trauma,
and then bring it into the present,
analyze it, and talk
about it, communicate.
Share the stories that are
associated with the trauma.
- I mean I agree.
I think you have to attend to the trauma,
and I do think that there's
a really important part in,
for therapy, that there's
another person there,
that it's actually a social activity.
It's not just on your own.
Thinking about it, confronting it,
but it's acknowledging,
and I think that's part of story telling.
It really is a way of being able
to tell your story to somebody,
your narrative and have it
understood in a way that's
accepted as a human experience,
but not as one that is
sort of faithful in a way.
That means that you're
constrained by that faith.
There certainly are,
for some things like PTSD,
there are lots of very
biological approaches
just trying to increase
the brain plasticity.
There are a lot of people
who try to do things
like exposure therapy for a phobia.
And I would say there it's really
part of the important thing
is that there's somebody else
who's there, who's helping
you relive that experience,
but relive it in a different way,
because it's not dangerous,
it's not threatening in the second,
in the reliving of it.
- Absolutely, and not to be alone
is the most important thing,
because your trauma is
all about being alone,
and not being able to deal with yourself,
not being proud of yourself,
in fact, being ashamed,
and to realize you're not the only person
who's going through this.
So what this means that it's shared,
that it's shared,
and again, we're also sure
something is wrong with us
and we're not dealing with
their systematic things going on
that are affecting
large numbers of people.
And when you begin to
realize you're not alone,
its a very, very deep thing.
I would just add on
behalf of the arts that
officially the Canadian government
is now saying the only treatment
that can actually be put
forward at the moment
for PTSD is music.
And music is being used
over and over again now
for returning Canadian soldiers
from Afghanistan and Iraq,
and it's being very,
very powerful results.
And music has a way of both liberating,
and relaxing, and opening,
and creating a spaciousness
of thought and feelings.
And at the same time, music can deal with
very, very intense emotional states.
And so music has had a
profound effect on soldiers
returning from these last wars.
- One last question from the audience.
Do we have a microphone?
Here we are.
- You were mentioning longer,
short-term memory and
long-term memory before.
So, why when we are very old
and near the end of our life,
we remember only things a long time ago
and we kinda don't want,
deny things that are present?
I don't know, you call
it short-term memory.
It's only a long-term memory.
It's very strange because
I'm thinking about the brain
that is corroding, that is getting old,
and actually you should
remember the last things
you just did, not the things
before because it's gone.
Instead, when you hear the last word
of people that almost died,
tell you things from the past,
from when they were young.
They remember the mother,
they tell you story that are really back,
and that strike me.
I would like to know as a scientist
what's happening to our brain.
(laughs)
- Well, I'm gonna,
Kelsey, this is your area of specialty.
Is it true that it's all in there,
it's just a matter of how we access it?
Is that what it really is?
How do these things work?
- Well, I mean--
(audience laughs)
- It's a good last question.
- I'll be perfectly honest that
not only do I not know
how they really work,
but nobody knows how they really work,
but I can tell you what
some hypothesis are,
which is that when I talked
about this brain plasticity
and about the ability of
forming different synapses,
that that's really good in young people.
It's not so good as you get older.
And so you really have
created these circuits
that are pretty hardwired,
and so you could remember
things from a long time ago,
but it's harder to have that plasticity
that's gonna encode new memories.
That's one of the things that,
to me, that is exactly what
I work on in my own lab,
is trying to understand what
at a molecular level is happening
that allows us to go from a short-term
to a long-term memory,
and what's that kind of plasticity.
Because it's both,
there's that
wonderful thing about
being a child that you can
learn new languages,
you can learn how to play the violin
much more easily than when you're older,
and there is that kind of
a little bit of a shrinking
down of that plasticity.
It's not all or none,
and we see people all over who continue,
and there are all these things
that show that if you
listen to music, if you dance,
if you do crosswords, you read,
that you keep that going.
But I do think it's something
that happens with aging,
you lose some of that brain plasticity.
You have all the old-term memories
because they're already stored.
You just don't have that ability
to like change the circuit.
- And I think also the encounter,
what we also remember is our
first encounter with something,
or our first encounter with someone.
And so it's when everything is new
that we actually remember it.
Our experience in
discovery is so profound.
And once you stop discovering,
once something isn't knew,
it's hard to create a new memory,
because you're actually repeating what...
Forgive me for saying this,
but my mother who's really
forgetting a lot these days,
is in a place where people
are helping to care for her.
They have a trip in a bus
in the afternoons to go out
to the beach in San Francisco,
and see the Golden Gate.
And my mother said to me two days ago,
"I've seen the water.
"I've seen the beach.
"I don't need to see those things."
And it's very intense because what is it
when you tell yourself
it's not a new experience.
You stop creating new experience.
- Thank you.
(applauding)
Everybody, we're gonna
have to draw the evening
to a close here.
I don't think,
I don't think it would be too self-aware
to say for everybody in the room,
thank you for an incredibly
memorable evening.
(audience laughs)
I think everyone in the audience,
please, please, help me
thank our three guest
for taking time out of
their very busy lives.
UCLA's dean of the David
Geffen School of Medicine,
Kelsey Martin.
UCLA's dean for Division
of Social Sciences,
world arts and cultures
professor, Peter Sellars.
And the memory of world arts cultures
Professor Polly Nooter Roberts
who is with us here also this evening.
Thank you everybody.